[Musique]
et nous sommes avec le général dominique
trinquant expert en géostratégie ancien
chef de la mission militaire française
auprès de l'onu de l'onu et alik
tounkara sociologue directeur du centre
des études sécuritaires et stratégiques
au sahel bonsoir à vous merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france alors
on voit le bilan et les très lourds 47
soldats français tués depuis 2013
la france doit-elle se désengager du
sahel général trinquant non les
modalités doivent évoluer
elle avait évolué d'ailleurs après le
sommet de peau je rappelle que la zone
des trois frontières dans lequel a eu
lieu l'attaqué
hier et la zone sur laquelle se
concentraient les forces françaises
il y avait eu un renforcement également
y avait une meilleure coordination avec
les forces du g5 celle puisqu'il y avait
un pc commun voilà les trois éléments
qui depuis un an ont amené beaucoup de
succès tactique sur le terrain
maintenant il est certain que la guerre
ne peut être gagnée que par les pays de
la région et donc la france n'est là que
pour aider au moins de février il y aura
une réunion qui fera un bilan de ce qui
s'est passé pendant cette année et des
décisions seront prises sur l'évolution
du dispositif
aussi bien le dispositif barkan
d'ailleurs que le dispositif du g5 sahel
malheureusement la guerre tue ça nous le
rappelle brutalement parfois il y a eu
47 soldats français tués pendant cette
opération
c'est un peu moins de la moitié de ce
qu'il ya eu en afghanistan est à peu
près un tiers de ce qu'il y avait eu en
yougoslavie
il faut qu'on se rappelle que la guerre
tu que c'est c'est pas le nos soldats
qui meurent remplissent leur mission
c'est un drame pour les familles c'est
un drame pour nous parce que ce sont des
frères d'armes qui meurent mais ça n'est
pas la fin des opérations pour autant
aller tounkara qu'en pensez vous en tout
cas le président emmanuel macron il a
salué la mémoire des trois militaires
décédés la rappeler quand même la
détermination de la france à poursuivre
la lutte contre le terrorisme
officiellement en tout cas
pas question pour l'instant de se
retirer de la région est
incontestablement la de tous les proches
et la force française et laisse quand
même une force indispensable au lieu des
8 d'accalmie cap au niveau du mali où
que tournait d'ailleurs les à elle de
façon générale et des médias aujourd'hui
effectivement l'état l'a appelé beaucoup
de milles d'avancé ont succombé dans
cette lutte contre cette force et
nuisibles et il a quand même bien
optimiste dans le fait que ce ne sont
pas seulement les forces françaises
notamment et qui sont les victimes de
ces forces
blueberry culpa dans les localités dites
de beaucoup les éléments des fautes de
france du mali et du niger mémoire est
également du burkina ont été également
victimes de cette attaque terroriste
donc en sommes là c'est qu'ils viennent
de s'affronter focal de la planète
elle souffre 1900 puis elle bouge et
compter les effectifs de la partie
l'état s'attaque ce soir côté mali niger
ou même au burkina donc c'est une
localité où ce sont deux localités ou
qui ont été cléments longuement déserté
par l'ue pour des états et à laquelle
désertion et l'institutionnel a
clairement favorisé les stations dans un
premier temps et des narcotrafiquants
nous dépasser à des immigrants et qui
traite les eaux mais il voulait gagner
l'occident et par ricochet on assiste un
partisan et nuit la venue massive de ces
coupes près du corps violent avec nous
l'échéance nice nantes / 7 / localités
ont dû malheureusement elle est en
quarts à aller allait-on terra le
général trinquant faisait allusion tout
à l'heure à des cordes des résultats
obtenus dans la région quel est l'état
des lieux justement en matière de
sécurité est ce que la situation elle a
empiré par exemple depuis la chute du
président malien ibrahim boubacar keita
ou pas du tout on peut pas établir des
lignes directes d'une possible
amélioration nations suite la suite chez
les u21 quitte à acheter des plus
inquiétants mais ce qui est certain
observable console côté mali beauté
bouqueniaux pop et l'hygiène les ai
quittés il continue à gagner du terrain
et où 321 2012-2013 c'était les zones
dites noires du manic et qui subissaient
ces différentes attaques
la part de ces groupes à découvrir mais
aujourd'hui nous assistons à une
opération descendez de l'invité du
centre et même une bonne partie je suis
dit mme à nouveau glisser les toucher
mais soit facilité l baasiste que les
différents efforts nous a permis à ces
différentes communautés
ah si c'est assez soulagement desquels
il faut quand même pas le gommer
c'est qu'elle sait qui tu es content
unis clairement assez vite dans ces
différentes localités de résister et me
mets dans le même temps tous ses défauts
constatés à la fois par les années pas
retenir les par les armées nationales
ont quand même permis qu avait assisté
au japon pouvait d'ebita calme en début
les changements de gimat a provoqué
l'irritation ces questions polies si je
pense que les mets au bilan au et
qu'avec cet instant en tellement
attaques terroristes en inde mais moi
dès les configurations de ces
différentes général train quand la
france c'est vrai elle n'est pas seule
dans la région il ya les armes et
d'ailleurs nationales des pays de cette
région il ya aussi la force européenne
takouba le g5 sel
la minus main pour le mali est-ce que sa
présence est indispensable encore une
fois et est ce que qu'est-ce qu'elle
bilan vous faites justement en matière
de coopération entre ces différents
éléments
alors le premier point qu'il faut
rappeler que les armées françaises sont
présentes à la demande des pays
africains d'abord l'opération serval à
la demande du mali et puis ensuite
l'opération barkan à la demande des cinq
pays du sahel
ça a été le cas en particulier à à pau
où le président de la république
emmanuel macron a demandé aux chefs
d'état africains de réitérer leur
demande d'appui des forces françaises
donc les forces françaises sont là à la
demande des pays africains alors il est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de force
vous parlez de barkan bien sûr du g5
sahel de la formule la mission de
formation de l'union européenne ue 6ème
et la minutie m'a tout ça ça fait
beaucoup de beaucoup de force et la
coordination n'est pas évidente
je répète qu'il y a eu un gros effort de
coordination qui a été fait depuis pau
en particulier entre le g5 sahel et la
force barkan maintenant arriver une
nouvelle force qui est la force takouba
donc les forces spéciales européennes
qui vont faire un travail
d'accompagnement des pays africains et
de travail un peu ciblées et je trouve
qu'il est très important que les
européens s'investissent parce que le
sujet n'est pas seulement un sujet
bilatérales entre la france et les pays
africains qui se trouve avoir été
d'anciennes colonies mais globalement
avec les européens parce que là les
batailles peuvent être gagnés par les
armées mais la guerre et la paix ne
seront gagnés que par les gouvernements
et par le développement et le
développement
c'est l'union européenne qui peut
arriver avec des moyens importants pour
permettre à ces régions qui ont vu une
explosion démographique absolument
incroyable depuis les 40 dernières
années
ne pouvant pas procurer de l'emploi et
du développement à ces populations qui
avait explosé et sa l'union européenne
peut être très utile là dedans
donc il ne s'agit pas seulement de
neutraliser les banques
elle est désormais bien développé est ce
qu'elle est assez utile l'union
européenne sur le plan justement du
développement économique des
partenariats écouter l'hymne européenne
est un outil extrêmement puissant mais
extrêmement lent donc je vous le concède
on aurait préféré qu'elle sainte qu'elle
s'investisse directement il y a six ou
sept ans mais déjà depuis un ou deux ans
elle s'investit beaucoup plus et les
européens sont présents aussi bien dans
le soutien militaire à l'opération
barkan que dans la présence à la minus
ma que maintenant avec takouba de la
présence avec le g5 sahel ça c'est pour
le côté militaire pour le côté
économique et financier il ya de plus en
plus d'investissements qui sont faits et
je crois que ça c'est un progrès énorme
d'avoir permis à l'union européenne de
regarder vers le sud et non pas
seulement vers l'est et de s'apercevoir
que tout ceci est à nos portes et que
c'est dans notre intérêt de permettre le
développement de ces pays allait
tounkara sur cette question justement de
la réponse qui ne doit pas être que
militaire on l'entend souvent mais on a
l'impression qu'à très peu d'actes
concrets posés
donc vous pensez que les possibilités
sont certes nécessaires mais les défis
schmeichel et d'ailleurs il faut quand
même le rappel avant d'amorcer le volet
développement
ces différentes forces en présence et
une gens-là bien appeler souffre d'une
réelle coordination effective quant à la
lys eux contre ces groupes est double
mais s'agissant du volet développement
et a posé pas concernés d'avoir de
commencer avec ses 10 ans en termes de
gouvernance
si vous écoutez quand même bu et les
relations qui vit dans ces différentes
localités
si elles ont une bonne attaque commun
ces dégâts tension et ce nombre à des
états ou les actes qu il incarne sont
des acteurs qui sont perçus comme des
prédateurs
ça sent une des questions qu'il faut
l'exil et les fondus de la gouvernance
même d'aller même temps se quitte à me
reprocher allée des pins germain au mans
c'est on est un peu dans les schémas qui
se passe à chemin ancré dans les
attentes légitimes dans les communautés
rurales notamment
et en termes clairs les grands projets
qui sont toujours portées par ligne un
seul projet tout à fait important mais
les projets des soins ne sont pas
formulées ou ne sont pas exprimés comme
bégin est pas une communauté dans ces
produits sont censés soulager la
souffrance patrik elias est tenu du
décalage entre les besoins satisfaits
par répartie développement à l'audience
du nord et les démantèlements formulées
par le bénéficiaire est d'amener les
gars ne passe pas y compris la phase 5
se ferait également 17 des déficits
d'ancrage des points de vue
anthropologique parce que sont la face
des communautés qui ont parfois des
désaccords as des complicités avec ce
couperet avec un violent donc vouloir
combattre les taux 10 mois on essaie de
possibilités ça mais je pense que
dernière réunion j'ai une dernière
question générale trinquant puisque vous
évoquez le sommet de peau on le sait
était question quand même de faire
évoluer justement là l'opération
française voire réduire peut-être cette
force déployée au sahel
jean castex qui va se rendre au tchad
pour le nouvel an le tchad on le
rappelle qui abrite le commandement de
l'opération barkan au sahel
que faut-il attendre
de cette rencontre de cette visite on
sait que la france s'est beaucoup appuyé
sur le tchad import maintenir la
sécurité au sahel
oui bien sûr tout d'abord après le
sommet de peau nous sommes à un an à peu
près après le sommet peau et au mois de
février il y aura de nouveau une réunion
probable ans qui se tiendra dans le
sahel et qui permettra de faire un point
et de faire évoluer le dispositif et je
pense qu'il était important que le
premier ministre aille sur place se
rendent compte voir concrètement ce qui
se passe aussi bien auprès du pc barkan
qu'auprès du président deby de façon à
se faire une opinion de façon à ce que
le président macron qui connaît très
bien la situation depuis le début de son
quinquennat qui a fait sa première
visite là-bas d'ailleurs puissent aussi
compter sur un premier ministre qui
évalue la situation avec lui et qu'ils
puissent contribuer à la réflexion et
aux décisions qui vont être prises à
l'est d'ankara justement le président
tchadien idriss deby on sait qu'il s'est
beaucoup impliqué dans la guerre au mali
côtés des soldats français en tout cas
et beaucoup de soldats tchadiens et
beaucoup de pertes aussi du côté du
tchad
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de cette
visite concrètement selon vous on sait
il faut quand même préciser aussi que le
tchad est un pays de l'afrique centrale
et qui est une crise aussi en
centrafrique actuellement je pense que
cette objectivité les armées africaines
de douaouda même mort qu'il avait fui
instant nombre de groupes l'eau certes
les années partenaires jouer l'examen
porte et dans cette liste compte que
vous perdez poudre blanche
mais je pense qu'on gatinois si ça nous
a fait cadeau ce pôle est question
d'aller plus loin et c'est qu'elle le
fait que les verts parce qu'ils sont
proposés par la famille cette pause est
pas de même les nations du natal
la munition sont des réponses
malheureusement et qui souffrait des
questions de commandes mois est ce vous
régaler aujourd'hui est d'aller sein de
la manière dont les folie's entre les
gamins et naturellement elle ce sont des
mouvements et qui sont ici ne l'est
aujourd'hui
les affaires les apostats fait qu'elle
souhaitait non seulement des copains
fiabilité soit effective
mais là l effectivité doit les amener
sur tout avec commandement commun mais
malheureusement je pense que ce sont des
conditions pas clairement posée parce
que deux larrons de bon niveau il est
installé utile lors de cette vente
conclue
ces questionnements les criquets sont
malheureusement souffre d'avoir des
éléments de réponse à ces combats et
notre assiette mais pas d'aussi
important ils étaient seulement est une
légende du dragon texte il ya un peu la
sauce française les façons une hygiène
de la munition et même les forces des
africaines et c'est toi façon présence
effectivement au delà des six musées 25
hommes de coopération qui dit nouveaux
lits et sur une mine commandée manche
partout et intel commandement commettent
avoir voulait permettre ces différentes
personnes militaires de tirer les idées
ce ponte mais certains riverains
commandement on est temps que nous
n'allons pas nous diviser istres vers
des victoires sont communes à tous ses
amis et ses sentiments dirigent et de
l'autre ses sentiments mes mains des
doutes quant à l'efficacité
vous pouvez allumer nous l'importante
population hors taxes à ce partenaire
l'aumône au logement et merci beaucoup à
vous à liedson carrasso sur le directeur
du centre des études sécuritaires et
stratégiques merci également à vous
général dominique trinquant expert en
géostratégie ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès de l'onu sion